[Music]
on april 8 2022 the european union
issued a fifth round of sanctions
against russia and ladies and gentlemen
i think that measures
on oil
and even jazz will also be needed sooner
or later did you get that even gas will
also be needed sooner or later in other
words not now
since the war in ukraine began the eu
has imposed sanctions that restrict the
flow of russian money and goods
they've targeted banks companies
individuals
but natural gas remains untouched
the eu gets nearly a quarter of its
energy from gas and nearly half of it
comes from russia the world's largest
gas exporter
russia delivers the vast majority of its
gas to europe through this network of
pipelines
and as the eu's largest economy nobody
buys more of it than germany
since the invasion of ukraine began
germany has paid russia about 220
million euros a day for gas
germany uses gas to heat more than 20
million homes and to power a lot of the
country's industry
and germany's government has spoken out
against sanctions that would limit the
flow of it
it's not possible to cut the gas
supplies
but with every payment germany makes to
russia's state-owned natural gas company
it's also paying for russia's war
so how did germany become so dependent
on russia for something as vital as
their energy supply
and why can't they quit
germany was at the literal center of the
cold war after world war ii a fortified
border separated independent west
germany from east germany and other
soviet satellite states
world war ii had left germany in ruins
but by the 1950s west germany was
experiencing a remarkable economic
recovery german industries like steel
prospered but they needed more energy to
power their growing economy
meanwhile over here in western siberia
the soviet union had just discovered
huge natural gas reserves
they had a network of pipelines to
supply major soviet cities but extending
their pipelines to potential customers
in europe would be a huge infrastructure
project
then in 1969 west germany elected a
chancellor with a new foreign policy
called ost politik focused on bringing
the two sides closer together through
dialogue and deals
energy provided a great opportunity and
west germany and the soviet union struck
a deal
the soviet union would supply west
germany with natural gas and in return
west germany would provide high quality
steel pipes to extend the pipelines
it was a major 20-year deal
to get how this deal locked germany in
it's important to understand what makes
piped natural gas different from other
energy sources
natural gas with coal and oil is one of
the three main fossil fuels used around
the world but unlike coal and oil which
can be shipped or rerouted worldwide
piped natural gas is a regional product
that depends on proximity to transport
it natural gas producers spend millions
of dollars to build pipelines that
connect producers and buyers because
these pipelines are such big and
permanent commitments gas deals can link
a buyer's energy infrastructure to the
sellers for
decades by the 80s the soviet union
built this pipeline network to europe
and by the 90s it was supplying germany
with 40
of its gas then the soviet union
collapsed
[Music]
russia's state-owned corporation gazprom
took over the old soviet gas pipelines
but the map had been redrawn russia's
main pipelines now ran through a newly
independent ukraine putting a key part
of their gas infrastructure on land they
no longer controlled so in order to
diversify the routes to germany russia
began building new ones in 1999 they
finished this pipeline that ran through
belarus and in 2005 they began building
the nordstream pipeline along the baltic
sea to reach germany directly
they also built pipelines inside germany
and opened a subsidiary there to operate
gas storage facilities including this
one here one of the largest in western
europe russia now had three routes
reaching germany as well as pipelines
and storage facilities inside germany
the gas trade was strong
but it had also changed russia's
relationship with europe
at the end of 2008 gas price
negotiations between russia and ukraine
fell apart a few days later russia cut
off gas to ukraine for 20 days
the thing is because ukraine was a major
transit country when russia cut off
their gas they cut off a lot of european
gas too
as a result all these countries saw a
drop in their supply and tens of
thousands lost heat in poland at least
11 people froze to death all this put
europe on alert it was now clear that
through gas flows russia held immense
power over europe but up here another
link to russia was in the works
nordstrom 2 a new 11 billion dollar
pipeline to run alongside the first
nordstream and double the capacity to
germany
then in 2014 russia annexed crimea and
invaded eastern ukraine
in response the eu issued a series of
sanctions some countries began to wean
themselves off russia's gas
but russian gas kept flowing the germany
in fact germany imported more gas than
ever before
[Music]
today as russia's atrocities in ukraine
continue to shock the world pressure on
germany is mounting but replacing
russia's gas isn't easy
because it's been piped to homes and
businesses for decades without a major
infrastructure overhaul russian natural
gas can only be replaced with other
natural gas
and germany's options for that are
limited the largest european natural gas
reserve here in the netherlands is
closing this year
gas from algeria and libya is
increasingly used in those countries
most of what is pumped to europe goes to
italy and spain and a southern gas
corridor connecting azerbaijan to europe
is not transporting as much as expected
the other option is liquefied natural
gas or lng that's gas that's been cooled
until it becomes liquid and can be
transported in these massive ships from
anywhere in the world
but it's a time-consuming and expensive
alternative that requires a lot of new
infrastructure in the last two decades
european countries have built lng
terminals along their coasts germany
plans to open three in the next five
years but as of today doesn't have any
replacing natural gas and all fossil
fuels with renewables is germany's
ultimate goal but that requires a
massive and expensive transition that
won't be complete until 2035.
meanwhile at home germans are demanding
action
according to this poll the majority of
germans support a boycott of russian gas
but economists predict that cutting gas
imports could cause an economic
recession that could cost hundreds of
thousands of jobs but they have taken
some steps
yet kind of certification
ii pipeline was cancelled they have also
reduced dependence on russia's gas by 15
percent and have taken over the gazprom
subsidiary that runs gas operations in
germany
but the government and business leaders
continue to push back against
sanctioning gas entirely
germany is stuck
and the stakes are now higher than ever
[Music]
you